[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis einen schönen guten Abend
wünsche ich Ihnen im Sport schauen wir
auf die Fußball-WM mit Norbert Lehmann
unsere großen Themen heute
Streit Thema deutscher Pass die FDP
kritisiert Pläne ihre ampelpartner die
das einbürgerungsrecht vereinfachen
sollen
gefährliche Engpässe in manchen
Kinderkliniken gibt es keine freien
Betten mehr
und Wunschtraum Achtelfinale bei der
Fußball-WM hofft die DFB-Elf mit etwas
Schützenhilfe der Spanier weiter auf die
k.o runter
[Musik]
Kanzler Scholz hat sich dafür
ausgesprochen ein bürgerungen zu
erleichtern wie vom SPD-geführten
Innenministerium vorgeschlagen und im
Koalitionsvertrag festgelegt allerdings
sind nicht mehr alle Koalitionspartner
dafür Kritik kommt aus der FDP und
Widerstand gibt es auch von den
Oppositionsparteien cdu/csu bevor wir
auf die politische Diskussion schauen
zeigt Ihnen Michael Verlad violand aber
erst einmal um welche geplanten
Änderungen es überhaupt geht
es ist ein besonderer Tag der an dem die
Einbürgerungsurkunde ausgehändigt wird
Voraussetzungen sind unter anderem
ausreichende Sprach- und
verfassungskenntnisse die
Bundesregierung will jetzt noch
schneller und leichter einbürgern
bislang beträgt die Wartezeit mindestens
acht Jahre künftig sollen es maximal
fünf sein
auch in Deutschland geborene Kinder
ausländischer Eltern sollen einfacher
deutsche werden können bislang musste
ein Elternteil 8 Jahre in Deutschland
leben geplant sind jetzt fünf Jahre
bei älteren migranten sollen der
Sprachnachweis und der Einbürgerungstest
wegfallen
stattdessen soll künftig die Fähigkeit
zur mündlichen Verständigung ausreichen
auch der Besitz mehrerer
Staatsbürgerschaften würde mit der
Reform einfacher werden bislang muss die
bisherige Staatsbürgerschaft in vielen
Fällen aufgegeben werden dies soll
entfallen
diese Pläne sorgen jetzt also für Streit
in der Ampelkoalition am Mittwoch berät
wohl das Kabinett über ein neues
einbürgerungsrecht über die Debatte
Andreas
mehr Fortschritt Wagen so die Devise der
frischgebackenen ampelregierung vor gut
einem Jahr dazu gehört auch ein
fortschrittliches
Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht mit der
Möglichkeit schnellerer Einbürgerungen
doch jetzt gibt es genau darüber Streit
zuvor schnell zu ungenau der falsche
Zeitpunkt findet die FDP die
Reformvorschläge der
bundesinnenministerin
beim Thema Zuwanderung brauchen wir auch
Steuerung wir brauchen Kontrolle und wir
müssen beim Thema Rückführung
Rückführungen besser werden nur die
Einbürgerung allein löst kein einziges
Problem dabei hatte die FDP im
Koalitionsvertrag ausdrücklich eine
leichteren und schnelleren Einbürgerung
zugestimmt jetzt wollen die Liberalen
erst die Zuwanderung nach Deutschland im
allgemeinen reformieren kein Widerspruch
findet die Innenministerin eine
Einbürgerung stehe erst am Ende der
Zuwanderung nach Deutschland
deswegen ist es auch ja ein Bekenntnis
für eine modernen offene Gesellschaft
die wir als Ampelkoalition ja auch in
den Vordergrund gestellt haben das ist
uns dreien ja sehr wichtig und deswegen
bin ich auch sicher dass wir da das
gemeinsam jetzt auch umsetzen können die
Union lehnt vor allem die Pläne für
mehrfach Staatsbürgerschaften ab und
findet die verkürzte Aufenthaltsdauer
vor einer Einbürgerung falsch da sind 86
Jahre glaube ich ein guter Zeitraum und
es kann zu gesellschaftlichen Spannungen
führen wenn man die Staatsbürgerschaft
relativ einfach innerhalb eines relativ
kurzen Zeitfensters bekommt wenn man
vielleicht auch die Mehrstaatlichkeit
zulässt weil man sich dann nicht
entscheiden muss will ich wirklich
Staatsbürger dieses Landes werden der
Bundeskanzler unterstützt heute
ausdrücklich die Pläne seiner
Innenministerin und lässt verlauten die
Koalition werde sich auf ein
fortschrittliches einbürgerungsrecht
verständigen
der Wiederaufbau und der Ukraine wird
hunderte Milliarden Euro kosten die
genauso Summe kann erst nach Kriegsende
beziffert werden
die Regierung in Kiew schätzt das
mindestens 750 Milliarden Euro benötigt
werden mehr als 35 Milliarden Euro haben
die G7 Staaten und die Europäische Union
bislang an Soforthilfe geleistet nun
wollen auch die Europäische
Investitionsbank und die Stadt Brüssel
helfen per Videoschalte war kia's
Bürgermeister Klitschko dort heute um
zusätzliche mitteler
im Brüsseler Rathaus ist der Krieg in
der Ukraine auf einmal ganz nah die
Investoren die Kiew helfen wollen wirken
sichtlich bewegt als sie die Bilder
sehen
Bürgermeister Klitschko der wegen des
Krieges in Kiew bleibt bekommt erstmal
450 Millionen Euro von der europäischen
Investmentbank für den Wiederaufbau
zugesichert
braucht dringend Hilfe wir brauchen
Generatoren Busse Krankenwagen und essen
aber wir werden trotz der Probleme nicht
aufgeben und Glauben an den Sieg über
Putins Diktatur
die Menschen in Kiew leiden müssen
täglich nach Trinkwasser suchen sie
haben Angst vor dem Winter Kiew hat
sogenannte Punkte der Unbesiegbarkeit
eingerichtet in denen es Strom und
Wasser gibt
zu Hause gibt es kein Licht ich kann da
nicht lernen und komme deshalb hierher
und dann fällt auch hier der Strom aus
aber der Generator liefert Notstrom
hier gibt es eine Zentralheizung es ist
warm und es gibt Trinkwasser der Ort ist
mit allem ausgestattet was wir zum Leben
brauchen
die EU richtet sich darauf ein die
Ukraine lange unterstützen zu müssen die
Winterhilfe ist dabei entscheidend
russland will die Ukraine in Dunkelheit
und Kälte versinken lassen deshalb
müssen wir weiterhelfen und alles
schicken was sie zum Überleben im Winter
brauchen
der Kampf ums Überleben Klitschkos
Botschaft Kiew braucht dafür die Hilfe
Europas
[Musik]
es ist noch nicht so lange her der galt
Russland als Chance für die deutsche
Wirtschaft viele Firmen investierten
dort was von heute aus betrachtet keine
gute Idee war Putins Krieg und als Folge
die Sanktionen haben das Geschäft
ruiniert die meisten Firmen haben ihre
Filialen dicht gemacht oder abgestoßen
was das bedeutet zeigt Sebastian eben
das VW Werk in Kaluga drei Stunden
entfernt von Moskau allein vergangenes
Jahr gingen hier 118.000 Autos vom Band
seit März steht das werkstiel
tausende Mitarbeiter sind in Kurzarbeit
und wie es mit VW in Russland
weitergehen soll ist unklar wir
beobachten die Situation ständig und
ziehen verschiedene Szenarien für die
Zukunft des Geschäftsbetriebs in
Russland in Betracht eine der Optionen
ist der Verkauf der Vermögenswerte der
Volkswagen Group Russ an eine dritte
Partei ein Verkauf der Vermögenswerte
immer mehr Großkonzerne gehen in
Russland diesen Weg an ihrer Stelle
treten oft einzelne Unternehmer wieder
deutsche Perry Neumann er hat früher als
Manager beim Speditionsunternehmen Kühne
und Nagel gearbeitet und jetzt dessen
Russland Anteile gekauft ich hätte es
mit mir nicht vereinbaren können 1000
Leute 1000 Familien praktisch auf die
Straße zu setzen oder ohne ohne Job zu
lassen und diese Möglichkeit hat uns
eine Zukunft eröffnet doch zur Wahrheit
gehört auch es geht um viel Geld
deutsche Unternehmer hatten Milliarden
in Russland investiert und vom Handel
profitiert jetzt spüren Sie die
Auswirkungen der Sanktionen deutlich
jahrelang war der deutsche Export auf
stabil hohem Niveau doch dieses Jahr
hatte sich halbiert bei russischen
Importen sieht es zwar auf den ersten
Blick besser aus was aber hauptsächlich
an den hohen Energiepreisen liegen
dürfte VW könnte sein Werk wieder
hochfahren doch ein Ende der Kämpfe in
der Ukraine und damit der Sanktionen ist
nicht in Sicht und so ziehen sich immer
mehr deutsche Unternehmen aus Russland
zurück
seit langem steht fest die Bundeswehr
hat zu wenig Munition und die
Lieferungen an die Ukraine haben die
Situation noch einmal verschärft im
Kanzleramt haben sich deshalb heute
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter von
Regierung und rüstungsindustrieindustrie
getroffen das Ziel schnell mehr Munition
zu produzieren dafür stehen 20
Milliarden Euro aus dem Sondervermögen
für die Bundeswehr zur Verfügung vor
allem die Union wird
Verteidigungsministerin Lambrecht vor zu
zögerlich beim Bestellen zu sein
nach dem massiven Protesten in China
gegen die corona-maßnahmen hat Peking
vereinzelt Lockerungen angekündigt so
sollen Eingänge von Wohnanlagen im
Lockdown nicht mehr blockiert werden
gegenüber den Demonstrierenden zeigt die
Regierung weiter keine Toleranz
zahlreiche Menschen wurden gestern Abend
festgenommen und auch heute starke
Polizeipräsenz auf den Straßen Videos
der Proteste im Netz werden gelöscht
viele lassen sich davon nicht
einschüchtern wie hier in Hongkong
demonstrierten sie friedlich weiter
zurück nach Deutschland
100.000 Sozialwohnungen im Jahr das
hatte sich die Ampelkoalition
vorgenommen aber jetzt befürchten
Kommunen und Wohnungswirtschaft das bis
zu 70% der geplanten Projekte wohl nicht
umgesetzt werden könnten ein drastischer
Einbruch Gründe steigende Baukosten und
Zinsen verschärfte Energiestandards
der sogenannte Vaterschaftsurlaub steht
im Koalitionsvertrag wird von der EU
angemahnt kommt aber erst später grund
sei die schwierige wirtschaftliche Lage
vieler Unternehmen sagt
Familienministerin Paul jetzt sei
geplant die zweiwöchige bezahlte Auszeit
für Partner nach der Geburt im Jahr 2024
einzuführen
zurzeit treten bei so vielen Kindern
Atemwegserkrankungen auf dass die
Deutsche Gesellschaft für Kinder und
Jugendmedizin vor einer wachsenden
Belastung der Kinderkliniken warnt Sorge
bereiten vor allem Infektionen mit dem
sogenannten RS-Virus dieser Erkrankung
verlaufen meist harmlos für Säuglinge
und Kleinkinder kann es aber
lebensgefährlich werden die Einzelheiten
von Svenja Domeyer
Christina Feiler sorgt sich um ihren
Sohn der kleine timo ist chronisch krank
jetzt bleibt den dreijährigen auch noch
ein Atemwegsinfekt zum zweiten Mal eine
Notaufnahme in der Kinderklinik Hannover
wir waren letzte Woche schon hier in der
MHH weil es eben schlecht geht und ja da
hat man uns nach Minden geschickt man
hat gesagt hier wäre alles gesperrt ganz
Hannover ist dicht Minden wäre die
nächste Stelle ein Behandlungsplatz eine
Autostunde entfernt längst kein
Einzelfall mehr viele Kinderkliniken
sind voll Schuld daran auch dass er es
atemwegs Virus bei Kinder durch die
kontaktarme corona-zeit häufig noch
nicht mit diesen Erregern konfrontiert
waren sind die Krankheitsverläufe jetzt
oft schwerer die Situation ist durchaus
dramatisch die Kinderkliniken waren
jetzt schon am Limit ihrer
Leistungsfähigkeit aber durch diese
massive infektwelle die uns gerade
trifft hat sich dieses Problem noch mal
weiter zugespitzt eine aktuelle Umfrage
unter 110 Kinderkliniken ergibt 39%
haben kein Bett mehr frei so auch hier
in Dortmund die hohe infektionslage
trifft dabei auf akuten Personalmangel
und chronisch unterfinanz Krankenhäuser
deswegen sind Kinderkliniken geschlossen
worden sind Stationen geschlossen worden
und Betten abgebaut worden und das bei
steigenden Fallzahlen wir haben mehr
Kinder die wir in den Kliniken Behandeln
mit weniger Betten und das führt uns
jedes Jahr wieder an das Limit letztes
Jahr war schon schlimm und dieses Jahr
ist es fast noch schlimmer die
Versorgung schwerstkranker sei aber
nicht gefährdet nur werden die kleinen
Patienten und ihre Eltern erstmal Geduld
mitbringen müssen
von einer Katastrophen Erfahrung der
Pandemie spricht der Deutsche Ethikrat
und kritisiert das vor allem jungen
Menschen dabei große Solidarität
abverlangt worden sei
geschlossene Kitas Schulen Unis von der
corona-krise waren 11 Millionen Kinder
und Jugendliche sowie drei Millionen
Studierende betroffen viele von ihnen
leiden noch heute unter psychischen oder
gesundheitlichen Folgen sie dürften
nicht erneut ins Hintertreffen geraten
jetzt in Energie oder Klimakrise
die Humboldt-Universität in Berlin
Wintersemester ein Stück Normalität doch
für viele Studierende wiegen die Folgen
der Pandemie schwer das ich mich schon
als Studierende Person
allein gelassen gefühlt habe war auf
jeden Fall nicht der Fokus so was da die
junge was damit die jüngeren Leuten
passiert lässt sich jetzt auch nicht
mehr ändern ist halt scheiße gelaufen
ich glaube das Problem ist vor allen
Dingen so ein bisschen wie bekomme ich
Hilfe wie schnell auch weil ich kenne
viele Leute die sechs Monate auf dem
Platz warten viele jüngere Menschen
brauchen dringend Hilfe Ärztinnen und
Ärzte schlagen Alarm also wir sehen
natürlich dass wir sehr viel mehr Kinder
haben die unter Bewegungsarmut leiden
und auch unter Fehlernährung und das
bedingt dann wiederum eine krankhafte
Fettsucht die sogenannte Adipositas und
das hat in einem enormen Maße während
der corona-maßnahmen zugenommen wir
sehen aber auch leider sehr viele
Jugendliche mit psychiatrischen
Symptomen oder jetzt auch schon
Erkrankungen in einem Ausmaß wie wir sie
nie erlebt haben der Deutsche Ethikrat
fordert mehr schulpsychologische
Angebote Beratung für Familien
Informationskampagnen die Politik müsste
die schwerwiegenden Folgen der Pandemie
und der corona-maßnahmen ernst nehmen
die Gesellschaft ist Kindern
Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen
bislang vieles schuldig geblieben
und auch wir vom deutschen Ethikrat
haben ihre Lage nicht nachdrücklich
genug beachtet und nicht ausreichend auf
konkretes gesellschaftliches und
politisches Handeln gedrungen das
jüngere ins Hintertreffen geraten dürfen
nicht wieder passieren sie müssten viel
mehr mit aller Kraft geschützt werden in
allen gesellschaftlichen Krisen
Ermittler von Europol haben ein
sogenanntes Drogen superkartell
zerschlagen 30 Tonnen Kokain wurden
beschlagnahmt 49 Verdächtige
festgenommen das ist die Bilanz der
Operation wüstenlicht über 11 Tage gab
es bereits in Europa und den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten dabei wurden
Kommandozentralen und die logistische
Infrastruktur der Gruppe ausgehoben laut
Schätzungen soll das Kartell rund ein
Drittel des kokain-
der größte aktive Vulkan der Welt der
Mauna Loa auf Hawaii ist ausgebrochen
nach einer langen Ruhepause von fast 40
Jahren die Eruption auf dem 4100 Meter
hohen Gipfel war auch auf dem
satellitenfilm zu sehen eine Gefahr für
umliegende Ortschaften durch Lavaströme
besteht aber laut zuständiger Behörde
zur Zeit nicht
und nun zur Fußball-WM Norbert und zum
eins zu eins der DFB-Elf in Spanien ja
eine Unentschieden dass ich ja schon
fast wie ein Sieg anfühlt starker
Auftritt der deutschen Mannschaft allen
Frauen natürlich vom Torschützen Niklas
Füllkrug das macht Hoffnung auf das
letzte und entscheidende Gruppenspiel am
Donnerstag gegen Costa Rica nach der
Kraftanstrengung heute einen
Entspannungstag es wird gerade gedehnt
aber auch geredet so auch mit Niklas
süle der beim Null zu eins gegen morata
zu spät kommt doch das fliegt ihm kämpft
sich zurück ins Spiel und erreicht mit
harter Arbeit noch ein Unentschieden die
Reaktion war gut von uns und
ja war ich denke er hat trotzdem das
Gegenteil ist einfach aber wir sind da
flieg beweist ein glückliches
händchenwechselt Niklas Füllkrug ein der
den späten Ausgleich erzielt und damit
für eine positive Grundstimmung sorgt
nur so ein Tor am Ende zum Ausgleich ist
ja dann doch immer ein bisschen mehr als
nur ein ausgleichstorf vom Gefühle und
dementsprechend versuchen wir den
Schwung mitzunehmen Füllkrug der super
Joker ist nun der Hoffnungsträger
[Applaus]
am Donnerstag von Anfang an dabei oder
wieder erst später als Joker
ja das werden wir Ihnen morgen auch
fragen denn dann kommt er zu DFB
Pressekonferenz Niklas Füllkrug ist auf
jeden Fall die Wiederentdeckung des
Neuners und ein robusten und
zweikampfstarken Stürmer wie ihn
Kandidat fb11 auf jeden Fall gegen Costa
Rica gebrauchen die englische Zeitung
The Times taufte ihn ehrfurchts voll den
Killer mit der Zahnlücke und dieser
Killer darf am Donnerstag gerne dabei
helfen Deutschland ins Achtelfinale zu
schießen Killer mit der Zahnlücke danke
Sven also am Donnerstag entscheidet sich
ob die dfb-11 weiter kommt und in der
ZDF heute App da haben wir für Sie alle
möglichen Szenarien mal durchgespielt
und zeigen unter welchen Umständen der
Achtelfinale Einzug noch klappen kann
und jetzt zu den heutigen Spielen mit
reichlich Spannung und reichlich Toren
Kamerun und Serbien trennten sich drei
zu drei Südkorea unterlag Ghana mit zwei
zu drei ja und vor wenigen Minuten
bezwang Brasilien die Schweiz mit 1 zu 0
die sellao da mit dem Achtelfinale
vor dem Spiel standen die
schwaft im Platz finden die Eidgenossen
dann nur schwer den Vorwärtsgang die
erste große Chance hat Brasilien nach 27
Minuten doch Jan Sommer im Schweizer Tor
kann den Schuss von Winnie Junior
abwehren wenig Höhepunkte für die Fans
in der ersten Halbzeit die Schweiz zu
Beginn der zweiten Hälfte mit ihrer
besten Aktion wirkliche Torgefahr aber
Fehlanzeige die kommt dann von Brasilien
kasimiro mit dem 1:0 für Brasilien bis
zur 83 Minute hat die Schweizer
Defensive funktioniert dann setzt sich
die offensiv Power der Südamerikaner
durch Brasilien steht da mit dem
Achtelfinale die Schweiz muss auf die
Entscheidung im letzten Gruppenspiel
gegen Serbien hoffen
und später noch Portugal gegen Uruguay
ein Sieg und Ronaldo und Co stünden dann
auch im Achtelfinale dankeschön
dazu fällt etwas Regen ab und wann es
kälter wird das erfahren Sie gleich von
Katja horneffer das heute journal läuft
um 21:45 Uhr mit Anne Gellinek auf
Wiedersehen
[Musik]